bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors le premier ministre
boris johnson et sa ministre de
l'intérieur prévoit donc un durcissement
du contrôle de l'immigration est ce que
pour vous ça ressemble à une manoeuvre
électorale bonjour alors bien entendu
l'électorat britannique va être tout
simplement réceptifs aux déclarations
anti immigration parce que c'est bien de
cela dont il s'agit
7 cette problématique c'est une
problématique qui est systématiquement
médiatisées
alors bien entendu actuellement il y a
de plus en plus de tentative de passage
à la frontière entre la france et le
royaume-uni donc la question doit se
poser la question est évoquée donc je ne
dis pas que la ministre de l'intérieur
tente de pousser sur un sujet qui n'a
pas lieu d'être
bien au contraire c'est un sujet qui
actuellement intrigué interpelle de plus
en plus les britanniques et de manière
je dirai tout à fait légitime mais c'est
un sujet aussi qui est en relation avec
le bric cité en relation avec l'union
européenne c'est à dire certainement je
pense à mon avis que ce flux migratoires
qui se précipitent se précipitent
d'une part parce que on sait que l'union
européenne va durcir certainement tout
comme les autres pays sa politique
migratoire
on sait que sur le sol français il y a
une volonté aujourd'hui d'accélérer tout
comme le souhaite aussi la mise
britannique
l'adp les demandes d'asile c'est à dire
d'avoir des décisions plus rapides et de
pouvoir expulser très rapidement les
personnes qui ont des décisions
négatives
donc je pense que bien évidemment c'est
un sujet pour l'électorat pour
satisfaire l'électorat mais c'est
également un sujet qui actuellement est
tout à fait légitime au royaume uni au
vu du nombre important de temps
native de passage qui a augmenté ces
derniers mois entre la france et le
royaume uni
alors justement le pacte millet à tort
de l'union européenne
est ce que le royaume uni est unie à ce
pacte d'une manière ou d'une autre
alors actuellement le royaume uni est en
période de transition jusqu'à décembre
donc les accords du dublin sont encore
je dirais applicables mais après
décembre 2001 il va falloir trouver des
accords bilatéraux avec chaque pays
puisque le royaume uni ne faisant plus
partie de l'europe ne pourra pas
utiliser les accords de dublin
par contre ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'il ya des accords qui préexiste et
qui sent en parallèle de ce qu'il ya pu
être prévu par l'europe notamment les
accords de touques et donc entre la
france et le royaume uni
le royaume uni continuent de donner
quand même des dotations assez
importante à la france pour que la
france puisse préparer tout simplement
et empêcher les migrants de passer donc
ce sont des millions d'euros qui sont
donnés par le royaume uni à la france
pour pouvoir vous peut pas tout
simplement sur les murs ont doté les
fonctionnaires de police qui sont à la
frontière
donc il y aura des accords mais ça ne se
refera plus de manière à mon avis global
avec l'union européenne se fera
uniquement de manière bilatérale entre
chaque
entre chaque pays et ce qui est certain
c'est contre la france et le royaume uni
l'accord va de touques et d'un
certainement se consolider par d'autres
rapports qui vont arriver mais il n'y
aura pas je dirais de manière globale
avec l'europe parce que on ne peut plus
aujourd'hui traités avec le royaume uni
de la même manière alors très rapidement
il ya des propositions qui ont été
faites pour renvoyer les migrants sur
l'île de sainte-hélène ou encore sur des
ferries
désaffecté est-ce que juridiquement le
gouvernement britannique est limité dans
ses actions notamment vis-à-vis des
conventions internationales
alors bien entendu il sera limité parce
que il y a tout simplement également
l'onu qui qui va regarder et qui va
surveiller d'ailleurs le haut
commissaire de l'onu donc des réfugiés
avait été choqué par le traitement des
migrants par l'europe notamment le fait
d'avoir attendu plusieurs semaines avant
d'apporter une assistance aux navires
qui sont restés en méditerranée donc le
royaume uni ne pourra pas se permettre
de faire des choses qui vont aller au
delà se dirait de la dignité humaine
mais on peut se poser la question
lorsqu'on entend les propos qui sont là
c'est assez inquiétant qui sont quand
même des propos anti immigration mais il
durer au delà de anti-immigration quand
on parle de mettre des tout simplement
des vagues pour pouvoir tout simplement
empêché les navires d'arrivée sans se
soucier une seule fois donc le souci se
soucient pas une seule fois de tout
simplement du danger qu'elle peut
qu'elle peut apporter à ces migrants
dont on peut se poser la question de
savoir jusqu'à quel point jusqu'à où il
rend donc le ministre de l'intérieur
pour pouvoir tout simplement réduire le
nombre de migrants qui vont arriver sur
le territoire du royaume uni annan ahmad
merci d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
que vous êtes spécialiste en droit des
étrangers en france merci d'avoir été en
direct sur rt france